this video is going to make me very
nostalgic
so a little while ago i made a video on
the step-by-step process of becoming a
licensed architect
all of the academic and all of the
professional requirements and the
examination process
to become a licensed architect in north
america
and one of my subscribers quentin
asked me if i could share my specific
personal experience
and how i was able to get my license
within just three and a half years after
uh graduating from architecture school
thanks for asking so that's what i'm
gonna be doing today i'm gonna be
talking about my internship experience
and my approach um throughout the whole
process
and i've broken it down into kind of six
tips that i think could be helpful for
you and before we start i should
probably note that this is not a
blueprint or a step-by-step process
manual because everyone's journey is
going to be different
based on where you are
what your priorities are and what your
skills are and even luck will probably
play into it
so this is the path that i took but
everyone's could look different i also
want to talk a little bit at the end
about
my thoughts on licensure now after going
through the process and
looking back at it if i had the
opportunity to redo it
how i would have done it differently
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i am
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design and also
some tools and strategies that can help
us have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture
so first the why why why
why was i in such a rush to get licensed
the average time for getting licensed is
somewhere around five years and a lot of
people take a lot longer to do it so my
situation was kind of a
anomaly i guess
so
when i finished my masters i moved back
to my hometown vancouver
to start working here
and that meant
that i didn't really have the
architecture community of friends that i
went to school with
most of my friends here in vancouver
were not in architecture
and because none of them had to do a
master's they'd already kind of been
working in their careers for a couple of
years
and
yes uh comparison is the thief of joy
but i
kind of started to feel really
behind in life so
that
kind of
lit a fire under my ass now
after actually getting licensed i am
seeing a lot more tangible benefits to
becoming licensed
like
an increase in salary and my overall
market value as an architect has
increased significantly
but i'm gonna be talking about all of
that in another video so there were
some
um i guess you could call them
strategies
to how i approached my licensure
and i've
kind of broken them down into six points
here
be selective where you intern so i
started working the summer after i
graduated from my master's
and the job search was quite tough
um i thought i had quite a good
portfolio and i had won quite a few
architectural awards but i was still
getting very few responses from firms so
when i finally did get an offer
i actually got two different offers from
two different firms around the same time
when that happened i was totally over
the moon
but
basically uh before i started
uh job searching i kind of asked a lot
of my older friends for some advice on
like how to pick the right firm and like
the whole
internship process
and a lot of them advised me to
try to look for a firm that could help
me get licensed as fast as possible
because apparently a lot of interns they
have to switch firms because
the firm that they were at they won't
put them on projects or they didn't have
projects that were in phases that they
had to get hours in
um
so
when you graduate it's very easy to
take the first job offer that you get
and
you
might think like oh i can stay here for
a little while
and move if it's not the right fit or if
i'm not getting the hours but actually
like if you're already working somewhere
it kind of takes a lot of effort to move
somewhere else
and
even if you do that process is going to
take months
so
now you've already wasted months of your
precious internship hours so
try to be pretty selective about it
right from the get-go
and ask a lot of questions during your
interview process
be direct
um
ask about how the firm helps interns
collect their hours
what kind of projects am i going to be
working on do you have like resources
to help me with the exam process and
yeah try to ask those questions even if
it's a little bit awkward
at least that way you've kind of done
your due diligence and you've done your
best to try to figure out what it's like
try to figure out what type of projects
you're going to be working on
[Music]
so the way your hours works is you can
use any project in your office to
collect hours in different categories
like they don't all have to be from one
project
so if you have a
new house that's in schematic design
phase you can use that project to
collect your
site analysis hours and like schematic
design hours
and if you have a project in ca um in
construction min then you can collect uh
ca hours from that particular project
the only problem with that is that
you're really getting like bits and
pieces of information and i think the
best learning experience is actually
if you see a project through
from start to finish
and so therefore i think a small project
will be much better for you like a house
or like a retrofit
because they have shorter time spans and
you can actually see the project through
from like beginning to schematic design
to construction to project closeout in
my office
my project was a small office renault
for the city of coquitlam
and i was a little bit concerned
actually because it's not a new building
so there wasn't any like site work or
like foundations that had to go in
but
what's more
important is that you see the
construction administration process
through the project's timeline and for
things like site analysis hours
there were projects in the office that
was going through that so that's kind of
how i got my hours for those
don't go after the money when you're
starting out
so remember how i was saying i got two
offers from two different firms
uh so i got an offer from a large firm
and i got an offer from a small firm
the large firm offered me
a whole 5 000 extra dollars
over at the small firm
and
it was actually pretty tempting to go
for the bigger firm because um well a
lot of my friends were going into big
firms and you know it's a little bit
cooler it's kind of the firm that you
kind of want to go into after you
graduate
and you have bigger projects and uh five
thousand dollars was a lot of money for
me at that time
um
but
after talking to a couple of the older
students who had already gone through
this process
um i decided to go with a smaller firm
just because
um i was pretty sure i was like 150
convinced that the small firm was gonna
help me get licensed fast and it really
seemed like they were willing to teach
and mentor young interns
and in fact one of the interns at the
well there was only one intern at the
firm
um
so yeah the intern
my friend warren he was actually at the
interview
and he was saying that
he ended up moving there from another
firm because he was having a hard time
getting his hours and he was saying that
there's a lot of responsibility
and he gets credit for his work and
another big thing uh for me was that i
would be working with the two principals
like not a project architect or
a senior architect like i would be
working with the principals
and um
i've been kind of working since i was 14
years old so
i've kind of learned that you should try
to go after
people you want to work with not
necessarily companies
because everything you see about a
company you
should assume is like a facade
so
um for me every time i have some kind of
indication of what the people are gonna
be like
and you know good people are pretty hard
to find
i do try to make a conscious effort to
go after that and this is actually still
one of the main factors
for me in choosing where i work
log your hours diligently and check in
with your project architect regularly so
i tracked my hours every single day for
everything that i did um in our time
tracking app
and i just added a hashtag for the
internship hours category so
let's say i was detailing a roof for a
house i would log those hours and add
the hashtag constructiondocuments
so when i have to submit my hours i can
just search up construction documents
and
it'll show me exactly how many hours i
have in that category
and
it's also going to tell me which project
it's in i also created an excel sheet
that adds all of the hours and kind of
tells me how many hours i have left in
each category
so if you want a copy of that
i'll leave the link below and you can
download it and use it as well the
category i had the hardest time filling
was the contract negotiations
which is
basically reviewing bids and rfis and
i had completed all of my hours and it
was just
that category that i was missing
and
our office didn't have any projects
going into tender at that time
so i talked to the principal and we kind
of came up with a creative solution
basically i helped them create a
checklist for um tenders
so like i read through all the questions
from contractors that came in during an
rfi process
and i kind of made a list of things that
we need to be sure to include in our
drawings or in documents
i also reviewed all of the bids and kind
of try to record any red flags that
we could anticipate for other projects
write your exams as fast as possible i
know when you finish school i'm sure the
last thing you want to do is write
another exam but
i think it's better to just rip off the
band-aid and get it over with you don't
actually have to wait till you finish
all of your 3 700 hours to write your
exams you can write them like as soon as
you finished 2 700 hours and yeah i
would just write them
try to write them as soon as possible
because
you're not really gonna have more time
next year and
sitting down and actually studying the
stuff and learning it is gonna make you
a better architect
and it's gonna make you more valuable to
the firm
and you're just gonna
be able to absorb more knowledge than
when you're just learning
on the job okay before we go into my
next argument i just want to share a
message from our sponsor skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
platform with tons of high quality
digestible classes for creatives where
you can explore new skills or refine
your existing skills there's courses on
photography
indesign photoshop or time management
i've been wanting to get back into
photography so i recently started taking
a short course called street photography
and it's been so nice to be able to
brush up my skills and share my progress
with the class
skillshare is designed specifically for
learning which means there's no ads and
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
build your library of skill sets it's
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual subscription but the first 1000
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description we'll get a free trial
of the premium membership so you can
test it out for yourself
so this is the journey that i took and
i'm pretty happy with it i'm happy with
my decision i feel more confident in my
abilities i got a
1.4 times salary increase uh the year
that i got licensed but i think there
are also some downsides to taking the
path that i took and kind of getting
licensed as fast as possible so recently
some of you guys know that i started
working at a
um like an international design firm
with really high design standards
and
um until i came into this firm i was
quite
a pragmatic person
i was more focused on like good project
management good client relationships and
like good execution of the project
rather than like the concept or the
design
which i
was kind of willing to
leap behind
for
because i actually thought that was what
being a real life architect is like
because i had never worked in an
architecture firm that was run
like so much like a design studio
um
i've worked at four firms so far
but working here kind of made me realize
that
i really want to see how other firms
operate like i really want to learn from
other principals and see their design
culture so that
is definitely something i could do
but i feel like once you get licensed
getting experience and like checking out
different firms
gets a little bit harder
because
you are
[Music]
fulfilling a more important role when
you
come into a firm
as a licensed architect you're typically
managing a project or you're
contributing to the firm in a pretty
essential way
that it would kind of cause a
pretty big wrench to the firm if you
just work there for a couple months and
left and
like out of respect for the people
working there and for your professional
reputation
um when you go into firm as a licensed
architect i think you should be thinking
more long term
but when you intern it's
a lot easier to jump around different
firms
um
you can kind of work somewhere for a
couple months and then you go somewhere
else
because you're
you're not really that important
your salary is much lower
your role is not as
essential
and so you can learn from so many
different architects this way
and like later on when you have to
decide um which firm to settle down in
you can kind of make a more informed
decision on like what kind of office you
want to
set your roots in and also if you want
to open your own office
you have more references to pull from of
course i'm saying this from the point of
view of having already paid back my
student loans and like having savings in
my bank account so maybe if that wasn't
the case i wouldn't even be thinking
like this
um
i mean like experience is kind of a
privileged concept right i'm definitely
happy with my choices because i really
like what i'm doing and i'm really happy
about where i'm at
but i have been observing
that my values have been shifting as i
get older
especially when it comes to
money and time
i think when i was a little bit younger
i was willing to trade my time and
experiences for money
or for the ability to make money faster
but now
i would much rather have more time
and more experiences
and
more
opportunity for learning over money but
i think this is totally normal
we change our circumstances change and
our priorities change inevitably
i think we just have to be mindful of
that and be flexible and also try to
make room in our days to reflect
and think about our values and where we
want to be in the future
anyways i would really love to know
where you are in your journey right now
and where you want to be in the next
three years let me know in the comments
below i can't wait to hear from you and
yeah thanks for watching
you